[Music]
this water is so clean you can drink it
[Music]
I've been drinking out of this river for
550 years
tastes like water that's because the
water here comes from one of the most
protected places in the United States
you can't get here with a car you can't
use a boat with a motor
we couldn't even fly our drone past this
point these are the boundary waters of
northern Minnesota Superior National
Forest
thousands of pristine lakes like this
one hundreds of thousands of people come
to see it every year you listen to the
sounds of the rapids you watch the eagle
fly overhead you paddle on still the
waters beyond your own but there's one
problem the Boundary Waters is just
outside one of the largest untapped
sources of copper in the world natural
resources of which your state has a lot
were put under lock and key since taking
office in 2017 the Trump administration
has opened up more than 13 million acres
of public land for drilling and mining
that's more than any previous
administration including a part of
Superior National Forest
right outside the Boundary Waters Copper
the mineral underneath the forest is the
wiring and our phones the pipes and our
walls and we also need it for electric
car batteries and solar panels and wind
turbines we need copper and there aren't
that many places in the world to get it
all this has renewed a really old and
complicated question when is it worth
risking the life above ground for the
riches underneath
the US has more than 600 million acres
of national parks monuments forests and
wilderness areas they are the brainchild
of President Theodore Roosevelt he
worried that the reckless speed logging
blast rock mining and oil drilling that
fueled the Industrial Revolution could
ruin the country's beauty and resources
for future generations so he created 150
national forests and parks 18 national
monuments and 51 bird sanctuaries we get
up on a high mountain somewhere and
remember that somebody saved that so
that you could have that experience and
that's an a kind of remarkable legacy we
call them drinking water lakes because
you can dip your cup right off the side
of your canoe and drink straight from
the lakes without even treating them or
anything
Jason owns a business that outfits
visitors for canoe trips in the Boundary
Waters they come here because what we
have is so special and it's so unique
you just can't you can't have this sort
of an experience anyplace else in the
world to have you know a million acres
totally undeveloped the recreation and
tourism industry here is big it brings
in about 77 million dollars a year the
problem is that's not enough to support
the entire region seasonal recreation
workers typically make about $25,000 a
year that's less than the state's
average income you're not going to be
able to raise a family on $25,000 a year
you're not gonna be able to buy a house
and this part of the state used to have
a different core industry iron mining
we've been mining up in this area for
well over a hundred years and so it has
if it's a big significance there are a
lot of second third fourth generation
miners that have always worked in the
mine or their family has worked in the
mine the company that plans to build the
mine near the Boundary Waters twin
metals has said they'll pay about ninety
thousand dollars a year which is well
over the state's average income but
copper mining is also risky in ways that
iron mining wasn't for the last two
years the twin metals company has been
collecting samples of the rock that they
plan to mine near the Boundary Waters
this is a typical core sample these
little blocks that you're seeing in here
really establish hollow beep we are
below ground surface once we hit this
seven hundred and fifty five feet this
is where we start seeing the minerals
the copper is locked inside this shiny
part here to get it out you have to
crush up the rock to a powder like
consistency copper only makes up about
1% of the sample which means 99% of it
is waste the crushed up Rock is
submerged in a solution that floats the
copper to the top it's eventually what
becomes wires pipes and everything else
and the waste rock sinks that's the
risky part it contains toxic elements
like arsenic lead and Mercury which were
previously trapped inside the rock and
usually when mining companies produce
toxic waste they store it in giant pits
like these but those pits don't always
hold up it may be the worst
environmental disaster in British
Columbia's history three million gallon
toxic stew of heavy metals poured
downstream devastation as far as the eye
can see
and the question that everyone here is
just stunned by is how this could ever
have been allowed to happen and even
when there isn't one of these huge
catastrophic spills abandoned mines
leaked millions of gallons of waste
industry mess these colors indicate
heavy metal contamination that poisons
aquatic life and taints drinking water a
lot of the economy that this region was
based on was getting gold silver out of
these hills and then left of a legacy of
pollution the cleanup cost taxpayers
millions of dollars long after mining
companies take their profits and leave
twin metals plans to store the waste
from its mine right here next to a river
that ultimately leads to the Boundary
Waters and instead of storing wastewater
in a pit their plan is to dry out the
waste and store it in stacks like these
on its website twin metals calls the dry
stack method environmentally friendly
but to support that they point to
another dry stack mine in Alaska where
the verdict isn't actually that clear
the Alaska mining companies own data
show that lead contaminated dust is
blowing off the dry stacks and they've
acknowledged that it could be getting
into the water and in aquatic life near
the mine scientists found elevated
levels of arsenic lead and Mercury
just like the Alaska mine the twin
metals mine would be surrounded by
interconnected waterways any pollution
would spread far beyond the initial
impact site
all this is why in 2016 the Obama
administration decided the risks of
copper mining here would be unacceptable
and said that twin metals couldn't do it
but two years later the Trump
administration reversed that decision
tonight I'm proudly announcing that we
will soon be taking the first steps to
rescind the federal withdrawal in
Superior National Forest and restore
mineral exploration for our amazing
people and miners in the 1980's the iron
mines of northeastern Minnesota started
to close these days unemployment there
has gone as high as 90% of the 15,000
Union men and women who work the Iron
Range mines more than 3000 are laid off
and hundreds more jobs are in jeopardy a
full-scale depression forcing thousands
of miners to abandon the area when the
layoffs happened in the mine we were all
we were all hit everyone was at daycare
was hit the hairdresser was hit the
grocery store was hit and not just the
people that were laid off that's because
mining jobs tend to not stick around I
actually worked in several different
states in the mining industry and one of
the things I noticed when I go back to
the places where I worked 20 years ago
none of those communities are thriving
you don't build long-term prosperity on
a mining industry industry and
conservation have always fought over the
best use of our public lands and the
people closest to those lands often have
differing visions for their own future
this proposed mine really puts the
sustainable wilderness edge economy that
going right now at risk and it's
definitely puts businesses like mine at
risk jobs are scarce up here good jobs I
should say ones with benefits where you
can raise a family put money aside for
your retirement so this this is a very
positive good hope for us for our towns
our families our kids in a speech in
1908 Teddy Roosevelt took stock of
America's industrial progress we have
become great in a material sense because
of the lavish use of our resources
he said but the time has come to inquire
seriously what will happen when our
forests are gone when the coal the iron
the oil and the gas are exhausted more
than a hundred years later many of the
most impressive human inventions
including those that could ultimately
eliminate the need for fossil fuels
still depend on resources like copper
resources that will run out someday
the question isn't really whether to let
companies mined for copper near the
Boundary Waters
it's whether the short-term gains are
worth changing places like this forever
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]